gary has a you know his hair sticking up
your old back eh I hate this games I was
warned my heart out to this guy and I
look up and he's [ __ ] sleep dude
living with Amy and her husband after
dating her I'm supposed to leave in
three weeks validated let's close out
your own review by doing this a list of
things in 2019 I hate my favorite list
of every year all right this is the list
we've compiled a list of everything that
I hated in 2019 and when I hear this
back I go man I'm [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] a movie theaters I hate the way
I look I hate Michael Jackson I [ __ ]
hate vinyl I [ __ ] hate people collect
vinyl I hate horse racing I got up early
this morning I hate that I [ __ ] hate
people and I hate the Internet I [ __ ]
hate top 40 I hate the city and a gym
teachers I hate driving with a passion I
hate swimming
I [ __ ] hate rattlesnakes I [ __ ]
hate women who go to his store they buy
a dress they wear it somewhere and then
they return it I [ __ ] hate Russia
oh my god the what there's nothing more
I hate on the planet than packing I hate
hotels
I hate fireworks I hate Halloween with
such a passion I hate parties
I hate daylight savings time I wish
there was just one time period I hate
that I hate this [ __ ] planet and the
people on it
Wow Wow lot of anger it starts off with
I hate puzzles yeah that's right that's
the person yes hello hello Richard was
in here telling me Gary has a huge nose
hair sticking out today anything crazy
Norman chelation season Jason's right
into he loved to do come on Gary yeah
you gotta clip those things like at
least once a week I had dude I used that
nail trimmer I did it on an ultra
Saturday the thing that you put on your
feet your fungus me another thing that
you know that world that deals like an
electric nose trimmer that's not a nail
trimmer sorry I think you misspoke you
speak so fast you called your
I'm in the [ __ ] octagon I'm a little
nervous to know if he could pull my air
oh no no yeah [ __ ] if he pulls it out
you'll sneeze that's why I make myself
sneeze by pulling out my nasal hairs but
do you sometimes cry Richard pull out
his hair up but you know I love it I
love it I love to sneeze but I have it'd
be really great wow that was a pretty
good moment on camera put that up on
Instagram hurt hey Richard your hair
Richard you're supposed to make a wish
trim his nose hairs more hi
Wow let me see it oh let me see that
oh my god it's great his nose hair is
white oh my god guys take a look my
throat
oh my why did you do it I was kidding oh
oh oh that's [ __ ] vile all right
it's literally tickle in the back of my
tongue just swallow this massive nose
hair berry few of us know how we were
conceived yeah I try to find out for my
mother
yeah what but that's such a big deal he
didn't watch Ronnie Lee yeah my parents
you saw your mom and dad caught my mom
and dad in a threesome
oh wow they didn't I wasn't home right I
can't were supposed to be out I was out
yeah and I came in on it
what was the penny I don't even think
they know I came in the [ __ ] house
well position the door was closed
did you beat off to while they were
doing it it's possibility there's
nothing notching your parents I didn't
do it while I was watching he was
listening I went back in my [ __ ] room
a jerk dog went back in my room and
sporty the dog Ronnie if I heard my
parents and through the door having a
threesome the last thing you would do is
go to my room and jerk off what I would
do is I probably vomit I mean dude it's
so you're so sexed up that your parents
having sex got you charged up and you
went in jerked off think about that like
you didn't try to see what I did I I
admitted to it what are you talking
about daddy's balls around her with you
you said you could see their feet and
stuff I remember being a ninth grade my
parents came home did you jerk off and I
heard it's to this day it traumatizes me
remembering it I remember like Angie is
so [ __ ] freaked out by it but I did
not get a hard-on that's a weird move
for parents to have sex so loud that
your kids can hear in the next they were
drunk from a wedding in Ronnie's case he
came home and they were having a
threesome yeah I was I see and then he
went upstairs what is it they didn't
hear me come on I would like run into
another
know what he pictured when he was up
there in his bathroom yeah I would run
into the other room and like hide he got
down on the floor to see and he saw they
feed and then he goes to his room like
what did you do like you had a boner
while you were listening to them or you
had the boner when you got in the room
when you got in your bedroom I already
had already had a bone I mean listening
to their voices having sex
think about this we hear in your mom and
dad and you got a bone people that's
what I heard I want you know boy it was
your in your parents house yeah I heard
why was it listen no but but rie my
father
ronzo a major [ __ ] but Ryan could you
excuse me Gary did you they were but I
wasn't thinking about it like that
run can you a minute to think about it
like a [ __ ] porno movie okay Ron can
you run can you imagine a world [ __ ]
look at me Ron I'm talking who was I
talking you didn't think of them as
people as just people like in a [ __ ]
movie but they're your parents I didn't
think of them that way
when I went and jerked off I thought as
a movie put a guard up hmm it's almost
like Ronnie's origin story like man or
Batman like how did Batman become Batman
like Ronnie so sexed up now
like he's on fire but like his origin
story is it came from like coming with
his parents when they were having a
threesome and I come from I just you
know a creep was born hey you know what
I mean that's kind of cool I'm a creep a
guy who used the date Amy Schumer she's
married now but she's the date Kyle
Dunnigan he's been here helping us all
week all right now doing little voices
and comedy stuff may I say you're almost
like a Pete Davidson because well you
dated Sarah yeah who was a very
beautiful woman you dated Amy yeah we
had a we had a moment there I'm home and
I'm yes I'm living right now with her
and her husband's yet to be careful
you're living with Amy and her house
after dating your boyfriend
while ago in his brief did you ever
leave her apartment or did you just say
look I'm saying I don't care if you get
beautiful what are you working on her
new show yes so you work out of her
apartment yeah mainly out of her
apartment so you're living with them
mm-hmm when I first got there was very
like oh you don't do that I got so
entitled within two days like the soap
was low and like what it was so khlo why
go check myself and say this first of
all so how long you been in her
apartment I've been there for a month
and a half she's and she's pissed off
like you're not leaving no she's been
very cool have your own room yes like a
marble bathroom between ahead like you
don't run into her husband and no we we
bro out really chests no kidding yeah
and all the foods like really good and
free maybe I'll stop by Asian cuz I'd
like my trash kind of packed it is yeah
not go I would love to play in chess
yeah be fun yeah I'm supposed to leave
in three weeks but I don't think he can
[ __ ] it mistake at what point are you
like a squatter when they when Amy the
show is completely written and there's
no reason for you to be there you have a
jerk off and I play all the time yeah
what do you do do you lock the door oh
yeah we have a lock on your door yeah
like the her husband like we'll just
kind of come in the first time luckily
nothing was going on but I now I lock it
excuse me I'm nude in here this is I've
got to get out of it this is like
suspended adolescence I've got a
temporary any of the guys were right for
me if they showed up my apartment I tase
them not inviting them in yeah but she's
pretty cool that way very cool the
Chiefs one
yeah the Chiefs are in the Super Bowl
Richard now told the guys around here
what he's planning to do is go to Kansas
City for the Super Bowl
and watch the game outside because in
Kansas City this time of year people sit
outside and watch the the football games
on a TV together in a group right I'm
Richard said I wanna be with real fans
now he's gonna
sit in the stadium are they doing no no
no stadium now lady you sit in front of
a bar but outside freezing Jerry put
Richards desk outside today let's see
how well even maybe that'll wake him up
what do you left now you're really gonna
get on a plane you got a kid you're
gonna fly to Kansas City first off can I
say how about them Chiefs who are you so
happy oh my god [ __ ] tears really I
don't watch football what's the getting
closer with it while they were down at
the beginning and then [ __ ] mahomes
I'm gonna [ __ ] cry he [ __ ] rules
man how come he's we have our
quarterback finally the Chiefs never
they always got quarterbacks from
somewhere else this is our [ __ ] guy
and he told me on wrap-up show last year
he said we're gonna get to Miami free
you and your dad and he [ __ ] did it
yeah in a parking lots yeah a lot of
money I hate to interrupt this but yeah
Richard's got an enormous booger hanging
from his nose missing yeah it's like
it's not icicle I'm close to me let me
look at or you can see it come close I
still don't see it oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] is wrong with you get a tissue here
disgusting yeah well you don't know that
was there Jesus thanks Gary I didn't
even know I'm gonna throw up
yeah well here we here's Richard crying
when he spoke to the Chiefs quarterback
all right you've just brought so much
happiness to people like me
and you know Chiefs fans I had so much
fun watching you this year you just made
us so happy this year and I I am so
excited for what's to come in the many
years ahead so thank you Patrick
no I appreciate it man appreciate
everything you said my hero is the guy
who shot bin Laden die when I meet him
yeah they're supposed to take the game
this seriously not you hey just sit
there and watch and you know mahomes
like what the [ __ ] wrong I did he was
like this guy's crazy think I don't want
this guy anywhere near me I appreciate
everything you said and hopefully we get
that Super Bowl for you here soon yeah I
hope to see you in Miami a year from now
Richard's going to be the parking lot
cornfield closing couch it I was the way
I kept doing it was through it the the
another favorite moment was when Ronnie
and Gary and truly took JD to the local
weed cafe they were great to us but JD
could not work the lighter like it was
weird as soon as I sat down at that
table and I saw that lighter there you
know when I when I do stuff on the show
I wait for stuff to happen that get made
fun of and I feel a lot lighter I knew I
was gonna get made fun of because I
didn't I was working a lighter I mean
doesn't take that much dexterity you
know I mean it's kind of easy well I was
the way I kept doing it was through with
the front of my thumb the top of it
instead of the side yeah I'm you know I
gotta tell you like the first time I
ever encountered a lighter I don't
really remember
that memorable and the reason it wasn't
memorable is like I just did it learning
breathing day ramping up to being able
to light I never smoked or anything I
don't know what to tell you but I mean
like making fine it's a basic
coordinator on fire I got a very
coordinated human being you're really
not are you so now you can work a liner
I wish we had a lighter I'd love to see
you do it I'm sure someone's got a
lighter thing can you light a match JD
I mean I'm sure I could I don't usually
but are you sure all right I'll take you
back in time here's JD trying to work
the lighter
all right so JD now has to join his hand
and the lighter in his left hand as if
it's the first time he's ever held a
lighter I can't he can't light it don't
album hurry this is a sterile flashing
by Tim he doesn't know how to use a
lighter JD can I give you a little hint
or just let him keep going no let's see
him light it happen it's not gonna
happen
what do you what did you probably you
put the lighter in one hand in your
light JD what are you lighter
yes and when you push down on that thing
you got to hold the red button down go
slow no JD you're really uncoordinated
Howie I really was crazy I felt that was
very hard to watch I'd show up
how do you do it hey there's a lighter
for JD
we got it on the fifth truck early man
yeah when those guys find that coke
bottle yeah yeah the best with him was
at one point he was trying to use two
fingers to light and like he was like
using two things
it's a one-hand operation crazy now yeah
you know what
JP in New York JP I'm on the app
watching our other father and all I'm
looking at in Gary in his belly how is
he on that Pelecanos
even using it you know I got a ton you
know buddy over my house on Friday night
and he said hey you do that exercise
bike the peloton what's that like and
I'm telling him how great it is and he
goes he knows Gary goes what's we Gary
he goes hey he's got one of those in
he's fat as [ __ ] what's going on I mean
you work out hard I've seen you even run
you run like a maniac why are you eating
so much food that like it's impossible
to lose weight yeah you know what I
definitely either what are you eating
do you eat all the fish in the ocean I
mean do you have a normal portion yeah I
get it
I'm the first one to tell me what you
eat when you wake up cuz I mean you a
peloton so this morning I had I have
eggs scrambled eggs good with avocado
that's it it's like no bread no bread
all right that so that's a good start
yeah but something happened I don't know
Freddy that maybe at lunch I goes
between either so you don't eat til
lunch I'll have a couple of pieces of
plantains or something like that
munchkins I have weren't you eating
caramel popcorn out of a can with a
spoon it was last week I'm not sitting
here and saying you're if I can find
chokolate on my office I'll eat
chocolate right in other words the eggs
in avocado a great start to the day
good start but then you start snacking
yeah it's a better story than if it were
say a bacon egg and cheese sandwich did
we don't us this morning I had one of
the Munchkins oh my god no one really
liked my duck well oh my god is right
I mean the one day I mean you're heavy
guide for romantic exercise you do we
kept this guy from buying an exercise
bike yeah shrieks wondering what what
Ronnie and his therapist talk oh I am
obsessed with it sometimes I sit in a
car and he'll tell me a little bit of
the dialogue really tell Robin why you
was how to switch psychiatrist cuz I was
like pouring my heart out to this guy
one day yeah and I look up and he's
[ __ ] sleep how did you sleep I would
have been Ronnie totally busted him too
like Ronnie was oh yeah how did you wake
him up I guess I said am i boring you
and what do you say he probably didn't
even understand he just like jumped up
you know like half asleep and he said no
I was just resting my eyes
yeah [ __ ] he was out right dick ass
he was you knew as I saw at first I saw
him like dozing oh you saw him trying to
stay awake and you know and I mean I
would think being Ronnie's therapist
[ __ ] on me like when I busted him
about it didn't I tell you he ate a big
meal or something yeah well my
appointment was like right after he had
lunch and I guess he was like in the
food coma every time he must have some
big lunch you know what full of cards
and I called his assistant and I go I'm
not really happy about this I think I'm
gonna split down on this guy and she
goes well maybe we can make schedule
your appointment before lunch so they
must add complaint but you command you
know Ronnie's pretty interesting like
hey so I jerked off to my parents and
just got a call and I'm like when I was
four I fingered my babysitter tearing a
wagon train on television it was her and
then and then i got a gum job from an
old massage therapist
yeah and then my babysitter stuck a
Lincoln Log in my ears hey wake up you
[ __ ]
well III thought about it afterwards I
should have just like snuck out any off
ya how many woke up alone I said to
Ronnie you can't go back there he's like
I know I'm not going I was I was totally
done I don't even remember oh you could
imagine why don't work
then this guy know took a [ __ ] in a box
and throw it out the window and then
[ __ ] box Ronnie came over then was this
chick how could you fall asleep during
Ronnie
well my first my first session with the
new guy was you know telling him about
what happened what do you say laughing
laughing about that's okay you shouldn't
laugh again inappropriate behavior
that's Ronnie gonna get cured weak
Ronnie has an idea you're sleeping I was
pissed I left what do you talk about
what do you mean I don't know what are
you talking about it a lot of things
does he know you wash your ass in the
sink I bet you're in there talking about
me know I've talked about you of course
yeah I've talked about you tell me I
want to tape that session when you're
talking about me talked about you yeah
let me tell you something I'm a damn
good guy that's what you should tell you
tell you man we were loyal to each other
I know I'll be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't get all worked up and then let
this guy [ __ ] lead you down the road
where I'm some kind of dick I'm not
gonna mention any names but this prick
got really angry at me for going to
Mexico recently powered Ernie you got
some [ __ ] nerve what you said why are
you bad-mouthing me for I [ __ ] did I
could see it on you you liar yeah real
kindness one [ __ ] yelled at me
from getting the wrong SUV limousine
yeah
then put the door on right a man named
[Laughter]
Ronnie said to us that he washes his ass
in the sink which is out of the shower
and has to go he doesn't get back in the
shower yes Ronnie so just demo this for
me okay what's the deal ya going the
hell you want me to do sure we got a
sink let's get something straight okay
yeah this is like an emergency thing
it's not like something I do every
[ __ ] day took a shovel one you to
number two when you take a shower and
you're washing [ __ ] out of your ass into
the shower it's going in the bathtub on
your feet or in the shower but I don't
do that all right
people who take a bath who just this
sitting in it okay yeah but you nobody
puts their I don't you don't have to
defend no all right okay we have a sink
it's all set up take off my jacket
go ahead yeah usually naked women yeah
I'm not getting naked so you could
forget that [ __ ] this is why we don't
let you in the Illuminati because you
wash your ass in the sink take as much
time as you can take much time so right
I wipe my ass go ahead real good go
ahead all nice and clean right all right
wipe my ass real good right
this is only an emergency all right we
get it okay all right now just show me
how you sit on this side so you get up
on the sink yeah remember I wipe my ass
already it's nice and clean right so I'm
just washing the remnants the remnants
out all right that's it what do you do
with your hands
what do you mean what I do it now what
do you do like you do you splash the
water in there do you know yeah I washed
my hand my wash my ass out and there's
the with the soap and it's
water not just some what [ __ ] my hand
yeah how do you get the water to your
sink is running so your ass into the
sink
no just like I'm sitting man just like
this and show me what you're doing and
then what is running here's the water
and you wash your ass you [ __ ] take a
towel you dry your Arab water in the
ball is there a no no no no no the water
is just running I see okay okay all
right that's it that's the whole thing
you had to buy a sink for that Wow so
you wouldn't you go to pick out a thing
do you hop up on it to see if you know
this actually this one's small man long
you have a bar of this soap that you
uses from the bar of soap that sits on
the sink right yeah yeah yeah and then
you just lean it I wash my hands and
everything afterwards everything's cool
Oh same thing if you're in the bathtub
taking a bad I don't know how people
take baths I think that's the most
unhealthy [ __ ] thing ever I ain't
worried about health alright thank you
very all right we got the mic sick do I
get [ __ ] diseases now there you go
there is Ronnie I never would have
occurred to me to do that good for you
all right the only one who does it
I guarantee it Oh people just won't
[ __ ] admit to it never heard of it
okay all right you you know I walked in
this morning
I'm Robins in a glass boot so she can't
hear me so it's almost like a game of
charades so I'm trying to act out I
called you last night and you don't even
know it your sign language is terrible
you would not be the person who invented
sign for the Deaf well I assumed you
already knew that I called you and you
knew what I was referring to but of
course you didn't well you don't put
your egg saw that you've made to me
right but you didn't you don't have any
time signature whether you're going to
call me I've already called me you'd be
terrible I should you sure rage with you
let me give you good Fred write down the
name of a title there's some a movie
just write down the name of a title of a
movie okay and I will act it out for
Robin let's see how long it takes her
due time how long it takes her to get it
because
good at this because it was alright
alright here we go
alright I hate games but all right here
we are you set in the clock I am alright
here we go
when I start you start Fred you got it
alright forwards
blown you blown are you drowning
are you what you you can't breathe
it's terrible at this you're underwater
someone else oh there was at least 30
seconds it was you don't see I'm making
wind right department-id I said no you
did what is wind when you got one word
so far okay alright go ahead
come what's the guy with the way I'm
with the week very good boy are you bad
no but I said blown you didn't you go no
that was terrible and I was yeah I know
how to do that and I don't even know how
to do how do you do Gone with the Wind
I just were trying what gone I'm gonna
act out Donna's gonna walk out and never
come back
he's going Oh gone with the wind you
were horrible I was what blows you away
but then you win say all right give me a
mad Department here's one more
you're terrible and then you look like
you were swimming uh you know like
what's this puffing out your cheeks when
you're blown all right you ready all
right all right
movie two words you're looking for
something see look when I hold up to I
mean second word I can't see he's
fighting battle the whole thing
you're fighting a battle two words the
first word or the second word would you
put your glasses on I held up two
fingers and you got first word are you
kidding me
oh here we go get it say it word war the
first word you only gave me it's two
words war which war Star Wars there you
go
[ __ ] how long do that so he's got a
minute and 15 seconds holy cow
no wonder you don't understand my
message you're the worst how good was I
Fred wasn't I doing it I thought you
were trying to do very well but it's
like you don't realize how difficult it
is gentlemen he knows what that was
second word I acted out I got that that
took you half 45 but I'm trying to
relate I didn't oh never mind
holy Matri one more come on I'm missing
here all morning play charades with you
we're being paid for this all right one
more Fred give me an easy one she's over
there she she wants it look good eye
again right I'm terrific at this I
didn't realize I was so good at God with
the wind terminator how am I gonna
[Music]
terminator how would I act that out I
don't I can't even imagine I can't do
Star Wars forget about the terminus
I'm just drawing a blank right now oh
wait no prize it's only ten million
movies I know just drawing a blank on
this by the way next Robin and I will
play tic-tac-toe on the radio I'm gonna
be good all right you ready
okay so raids I hate charades but
alright though I'm making a point I
think I was signaling you that I could I
said your signs were bad and it's still
one this one I think is possible all
right all right
is it okay okay here we go alright three
words
word number to your old backaches you're
in pain
backache I hate this game okay first
word first Brokeback Mountain thank you
don't yell at me she did it under 45
seconds yeah better badder 9e gettin it
I have a heart attack from this game so
much pressure my acting is awesome you
sure you want to try and although now oh
come on that's ridiculous
three people are now listening
[Laughter]
[Music]
the Howard Stern Show